اهلا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه الخاصه
وفيها نناقش تدهور الاوضاع الصحيه في غزه
في ظل استمرار الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باستهداف المنظومه الصحيه اذ قال مدير
مكتب الاعلام الحكومي ان نحو ثلث مليون
شخص في قطاع غزه اصيبوا بامراض معديه ك
الامراض الجلديه والجهاز التنفسي ولنش
نستضيف من القاهره الدكتور عبد الماجد
العلول الخبير بالشان الانساني ومدير
جمعيه زي ديستك للعمل الانسن لكن قبل
البدء في مناقشه هذا الملف نذكر ايضا مره
اخرى بحصي الشهداء جراء الحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه ارتفع عدد الضحايا الى اكثر
من 20 ال شهيد بحسب وزاره الصحه في قطاع
غزه من بين هؤلاء
8000 طفل ومن بين الشهداء
ايضا
6100 امراه هؤلاء يمثلون 70% تقريبا من
عدد الشهداء عدد الجرحى وصل الى
5332 وذلك منذ السابع من اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي مدير مكتب الاعلام الحكومي
في غزه وصف الاوضاع في غزه بالكارثي في ظل
مانع الاحتلال ادخال الادويه والوقود
واشار الى تفشي الامراض المعديه كالامارد
الجلديه وامراض الجهاز التنفسي وقال مدير
المكتب الاعلام الحكومي في غزه ان اكثر من
355000 شخص اصيبوا بامراض معديه داخل
وخارج مراكز الايواء والنزوح في غزه اشار
كذلك الى ان
6500 جثمان لا تزال تحت الانقاض حتى هذه
اللحظه بعد مرور 77 يوما على بدء هذه
الحرب لم تتمكن الطواقم الطبيه من انتشال
ج جثثهم وهذا كله يسبب ويزيد من انتشار
الاوبيا الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني يقول من
جانبه ان 800000
فلسطيني في شمال القطاع محرومون تقريبا من
كل الخدمات بما في ذلك الخدمات
الطبيه نرحب بضيفنا من القاهره اذا دكتور
عبد الماجد العلول الخبير بشد الانساني
ومدير جمعيه غزي ديستك للعمل
الانساني طبعا هو هو وضع ماساوي في غزه لا
يمكن ان نجد الكلمات الكافيه للتعبير عن
ماساوي ه وعن كارثه لكن ما هو الخطر
الان الماثل فيما يتعلق بال الحالات
الوبائيه هل هل نحن امام حاله وبائيه يمكن
ان تحدث في غزه وان الظروف مهيئه
لها طبعا عندما عندما نتكلم عن قطاع غزه
الان في الواقع الحالي فاننا لابد ان
نتكلم عن بعض الامور الاتيه فيما يخص
الاوضاع الوبائيه اولا الناس في في قطاع
غزه الان لا يجدون الماء العذبه ل
يشربونها هم الان يشربون مياه ملوثه بنسبه
97% وهذا يزيد من حاله الامراض في الناس
الشيء الثاني الناس يعانون الح في الوقت
الحالي من سوء التغذيه لانهم لا يستطيعون
ان يتناولوا الطعام الكافي وان وجد الطعام
فان الطعام ليس مغذي بما بما فيه الكفايه
الشيء الثالث يتكلم على ان الناس الان
نازحون في مراكز الايواء وبالتالي هم
مقدسون سواء كانوا في مراكز الاواء او في
المنازل وهذا ينقل العدوى بشكل سريع ما
بين الناس الشيء الرابع ايضا ان الناس لا
يتلقون العلاج اللازم في هذه الظروف
فالمستشفيات معظمها تم تحييدها وماتس طبيه
معظمها تم تحييدها معظمها لا يعمل بالتالي
لا يتلقون العلاج اللازم وهذا يزيد من
مضاعفه الامراض وتناقلها ما بين الناس
ايضا كما ذكرتم
فانج ثث التي لم يتم انتشالها حتى الان من
تحت الانقاذ او المفقودين هذا ايضا يؤدي
ويزيد من وتيره الاوبئه داخل قطاع غزه
المشاهد التي نراها الان من قطاع غزه
بانتشار الاوبئه ما بين الناس تنذر بشيء
خطير جدا سواء كان على مستوى الاوبئه او
على مستوى انتشار الامراض الموسميه الناس
الان تح بالرغم انهم تحت القصف وتحت النار
وتحت الخوف وتحت الجوع الا انهم ايضا هم
الان تحت انتشار الاوبئه والامراض
الموسميه ف معاناتهم تزيد خاصه مع دخول
فصل
الشتاء وهطول الامطار والجو البارد في
قطاع غزه هذا هذا كله يؤدي مجتمعا الى
يعني بيئه مواتيه وبيئه سريعه التفاعل
باتجاه انتشار الاوبئه والامراض الموسميه
واي نوع من الاوبئه تحديدا الذي يخشى
انتشاره في ظل هذه
الظروف يعني الاوبئه مثلا الجلديه
اوبئه المتعلقه بموضوع اللي هو هو اي يعني
مثلا يعني هك فار بين اوبئه وبين امراض
معديه يعني يمكن ان نقول نحن نتحدث هنا عن
اوبئه ام عن امراض
معديه عن عن الجانبين يعني الاوبئه يعني
هناك يمكن ان يكون هناك تشار الاوبئه
الجلديه اوبئه مثلا يعني اخرى انواع اخرى
من انواع الاوبئه وايضا ايضا الامراض
الموسميه وهي ايضا لست سهله يعني مثل
الفلونزا وما الى ذلك من هذه الاشياء
الاخرى هذ هذه الظروف البيئيه هذه الظروف
الصعبه يعني او الظروف التي يعيشها قطاع
غزه هي ظروف يعني تسهل هذه انتشار هذه
الاوبئه وهذه الامراض الموسميه في ظل هو
قله الدواء الموجود وفي قله اللي هو
امكانيه
العلاج وا استطاله امد هذه العوامل شكرا
جزيلا لك من القاهره الدكتور عبد الماجد
العلول الخبير بشان الانساني مدير جمعيه
غزه ستك للعمل
الانساني ختام هذذه النافذه الانسانيه في
امان الله